أوروبا تعلنها
مخزوننا العسكري ينفد ولا يكفي.
وبعد فشلهم بفرض العقوبات على
موسكو اعين الاوروبيين تتجه نحو
تركيا وحل بريطاني لتربح
اوكرانيا الحرب قريبا. والناتو
يؤجج التوترات اكثر على حدود
روسيا هل يرد الروس كما وعدوا?
والصين في مرمى اهداف اليابان
بعد الاستنجاد بامريكا. واردوغان
على طريقة مجنون كوريا نصنع
اسلحة بايدينا فلتنتظر القادم.
ايران تعترض السفن الامريكية
والخليجيون يردون. ولندن تكتشف
علاجا لسرطان الدم واول حالة يتم
علاجها. وقبل ان نغوص في فيديو
اليوم وحصيلة الاخبار لدي طلب
منكم متابعي قناة شهد لتعرف.
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
سيحضر مباراة نصف نهائي كأس
العالم بين المغرب وفرنسا. وبهذه
المناسبة في ماكون الذي ذم ديننا
ونبينا محمدا صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم فاننا نطلب من كل المشجعين
الذين سيحضرون المباراة ان
يرددوا الصلاة على النبي بشكل
متكرر من قلب الحدث. اوروبا
تعترف لروسيا. الحرب سيئة على
المتحاربين. لكنها اسوأ على
الجيران. نعم. اوروبا تعاني
الامرين بسبب الحرب ها هو مسؤول
السياسة الخارجية في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل يؤكد ان
حرب اوكرانيا كشفت عدم كفاية
المخزون الاوروبي العسكري وهشاشة
سلاسل التوريد لكنه استدرك بقوله
يجب ان نستثمر اكثر لاعداد
الجيوش الاوروبية بهدف مواجهة
عالم اكثر خطورة. بوريل عاد واكد
وجود خلافات بشأن عقوبات جديدة
على روسيا وان نقاشات بشأنها لم
تنتهي بعد. لكنه شدد على اهمية
عدم مساعدة تركيا لروسيا للافلات
من العقوبات والصحف الروسية ترد.
ان اوروبا في الحقيقة تحسد تركيا
على فوائد التعاون مع روسيا.
ليتجه حلف الناتو لتنفيذ تدريبات
داخل مواقع عدة في القارة
الاوروبية وفي مناطق شمال
بولندا. وقال الحلف ان الغرض من
هذه التدريبات تعزيز وحدة الناتو
وزيادة قابلية التشغيل البيني
للحلفاء من الناحية الاجرائية
لكن ماذا عن التحذيرات الروسية
يا هؤلاء فيما كثرت في الفترة
الاخيرة الدعوات لاجراء مفاوضات
سلام لحل ازمة اوكرانيا في
مقابلها تم تكثيف الدعم الغربي
لكييف من يسبق الدعم ام السلام؟
الولايات المتحدة تقوم بالامرين
بالزخم نفسه شكر زيلنسكي واشنطن
على دعمها المكثف للاوكرانيين.
في المقابل يتحدث البعض عن ترحيب
بايدن بانفتاح الرئيس الاوكراني
على اتفاق سلام عادل مع روسيا
مبني على ميثاق الامم المتحدة.
ليتجه الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي
الى الهاتف وهناك ناقش مع نظيره
الفرنسي ماكرون التعاون في مجالي
الدفاع والطاقة الى جانب النقاط
العشر لتحقيق السلام وفقا لصيغة
ظل يناقش ايضا على الهاتف لكن
هذه المرة مع نظيره التركي
اردوغان ليبحث امكانية توسيع ممر
التصدير في البحر الاسود فهل
تجدي كل هذه المناقشات اما على
الارض فالمعارك تشتد اشتعالا
برغم الصقيع في الاراضي
الاوكرانية حيث اعلنت الدفاع
الروسية اسقاط خمسة صواريخ هاي
مارس في دونيتسك ومقتل مائة
وخمسة وسبعين جندي كرانيا في عدة
مناطق اوكرانية بينما سقط اكثر
من مائتين وخمسة وثلاثين صاروخا
وقذيفة اوكرانية استهدفت البنية
التحتية خلال اربع وعشرين ساعة
في دونيتك وذلك بحسب السلطات
المحلية الموالية لروسيا هناك.
ليخرج مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
قائلا انه في حال سقطت مدينة في
جنوب اوكرانيا سينهار خط الدفاع
باكمله على طول الطريق في خرسون.
وستحصل القوات الاوكرانية على
طريق مباشر الى شبه جزيرة القرم.
هناك اتهم وزير الخارجية
البريطاني جيمس كليفيرلي بوتين
بخرق القانون وتحدي النظام
الدولي. واكد دعم بريطانيا
لاوكرانيا بكافة السبل المتاحة.
ليأتي الحل للاوكران من
بريطانيا. فبعد توقع اطالة يمد
الحرب وتكبد الطرفين كثيرا من
الخسائر ثلاثة اسلحة تحتاج لها
اوكرانيا لكسب الحرب مع روسيا.
اولا دبابات ومدرعات مصاحبة لها
في عملية مشتركة. ثانيا انظمة
صواريخ بعيدة المدى. ثالثا قوة
جوية متمثلة في المقاتلات وبحسب
خبير عسكري بريطاني بهذه الاسلحة
ستنتهي الحرب بانتصار اوكراني.
لا زلنا في بريطانيا. لكن حيث
تعرض نقابة التمريض تعليق
الاضراب مقابل مفاوضات بتحسين
الاجور. لكن رد الحكومة
البريطانية كان مفاجئا بقبولها
التفاوض ولكن من اجل تحسين
الاداء وظروف العمل وليس من اجل
الاجور. وبالعودة للحرب
الاوكرانية دعا وزير الخارجية
السعودي فيصل بن فرحان امريكا
للحديث مع روسيا حول الصراع في
اوكرانيا مؤكدا على قوة بين
واشنطن والرياض. اليابان تتحضر
لمواجهة الصين. التطور العسكري
للصين يذهل العالم. لكنه يخيف
الامريكان كما نعلم. وهنا ظهرت
دولة اخرى تخاف من تقدم بكين.
نعم انها اليابان. ففي الوقت
الذي تقوم فيه الصين بتحديث
عسكري شامل بخلاف تقدم برنامج
كوريا الشمالية النووي وايضا نشر
روس انظمة دفاعية صاروخية على
احدى جزر الكوري المتنازع عليها.
وبسبب التهديدات الامنية
المتزايدة وخطر اندلاع حرب في
منطقة المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
اليابان تندفع لشراء مئات صواريخ
توماهوك الامريكية كجزء من تعزيز
دفاعي كبير وغير مسبوق في فترة
ما بعد الحرب العالمية الثانية.
ونقلت صحيفة واشنطن بوست عن
مسؤول قولا ان قرار شراء المئات
من صواريخ توما هوك بعدد يصل الى
اربعمائة او خمسمائة صاروخ حسب
بعض الروايات سيجعل الصين وكوريا
الشمالية على علم بان اليابان
جادة بشأن الدفاع عن النفس وان
التحالف الثنائي الذي يمكن القول
انه الاهم عسكريا في المنطقة
يزداد قوة. فالاهداف العسكرية
الصينية في متناول اليد لطوكيو
الان. هل يكفي ذلك لمقارعة اصحاب
العيون الضيقة? تركيا في النادي
الباليستي. سباق التسلح ليس حكرا
على احد. والاتراك يقولون لا
ينقصنا شيء لندخل نادي اقوى
المصنعين للسلاح عالميا وها هو
اردوجان يقولها. تركيا وصلت الى
مرحلة باتت تعتمد فيها على نفسها
في الصناعات الدفاعية. واضاف ان
بعض هذه الصناعات باتت تخيف
الجيران ليختبر الرئيس التركي
صاروخا بالستيا قال انه يثير خوف
اليونان هذا الصاروخ لديه
امكانية لضرب اهداف على بعد
خمسمائة وواحد وستين كيلومترا في
اربعمائة وست وخمسين ثانية لتكون
بمثابة المرة الاولى التي تتجاوز
فيها تركيا عتبة ثلاثمائة
كيلومتر بحسب وكالة بلومبرج. فيا
له من مذهل ايها العثمانيون. وفي
السياق ذاته اعلن اردوغان ان
بلاده رفعت خلال العقدين
الاخيرين حجم ميزانية المشاريع
الدفاعية من خمسة مليارات ونصف
المليار دولار الى خمسة وسبعين
مليار دولار. وبعد هذا كله اكد
اردوجان في اتصال هاتفي مع بوتين
ان الفصائل الكردية مستمرة في
استهداف الداخل التركي. مبينا
ضرورة تطهير المنطقة ممن وصفهم
بالارهابيين. الاحداث والتطورات.
في واقعة غريبة تاجر مخدرات مصري
يروج لممنوعاته بنشر رقم هاتفه
وعنوانه مع تخصيص رقم خاص لشكاوى
ما بعد البيع ليكون اول زبون
يتصل به هو رئيس المباحث وكما
يقولها المصريون قائد بحرية
الحرس الثوري الايراني. اعترضنا
امريكيتين في مياه الخليج
الاسبوع الماضي. وزير الخارجية
السعودي من حق الدول الخليجية
ضمان امنها ومن غير اتفاق نووي
مع ايران ستدخل المنطقة في مرحلة
معقدة. تعافت طفلة مصابة بسرطان
الدم بعد خضوعها لعلاج بتقنية
التعديل الوراثي في بريطانيا.
فهل وجد الانجليز العلاج لهذا
المرض الخبيث? في لبنان تتفاقم
لتصبح الاعلى عربيا. فاين
المشمرون للزواج? واين انتم ايها
العرب? وضع اوروبا بعد تسعة اشهر
من حرب اوكرانيا سيء جدا. فكيف
للاوروبيين ان يتعاملوا مع هكذا
وضع اذا طالت الحرب لسنوات اخرى?